sadly enough we've come to it we have
come to the concluding chapter of the
bread Batman Arkham Knight so Batman
Arkham Knight is the third Arkham game
in Rock Steady's Arkham trilogy and
although Arkham Knight does give some
nods to the events in Arkham origins
ultimately it is a trilogy arkham asylum
arkham city arkham knight the plot in
Batman Arkham Knight is scarecrow comes
on the scene he's like Gotham I'm gonna
gas all of you so Gotham completely
evacuates leaving the Batman to deal
with it Oh Batman and the police cuz you
got to have James Gordon and this is one
of the praises I can give this game the
entire time you know it's the end game
right from the opening titles you know
Batman Arkham City hey was all heroic
you know and he's like on the rooftop as
I good oh good I was like just crazy
choir music every time you push a menu
he jumps off he's flying this was
literally Batman and the shadows all
like boom boom boom boom I was like yeah
that's the concluding chapter of a
trilogy right there if you played the
other Arkham games you're gonna be right
at home with the combat in this game
it's everything you know everything you
love and again they give you more
mechanics they give you new mechanics
new combos new things you can do I love
the multi fear takedowns one of the best
additions ever I've seen that mechanic
before in a couple of Metal Gear Solid
games so it was no surprise to see it
here there's just such a smart mechanic
you're gonna borrow something yeah
borrow that has Batman that's what these
Arkham games do this what Arkham City
does it put you in the driver's seat put
you in the body of the Batman you're
taking people down with fear you're
being stealthy you want to go out and
balls out combat cool you're probably
gonna get shot up a bit you got to play
it smart in this game you got to be the
detective they show more detective modes
because you're tracking down the serial
killer there's a lot of site things to
do in this game one of the things is
there's these bodies and you have to go
into Detective Mode you scan their body
scan their tissue you have to identify
these people and hopefully track this
dude down and yes the Riddler trophies
are back forever I love the Riddler
trophy so when I saw him in this game I
was like thank God I don't know what an
Arkham game would be without the Riddler
trophy and then giving you a lot of new
gear there is one huge piece of gear
that is new to this game and that is the
Batmobile I've heard mixed reactions for
the Batmobile ultimately I had a lot of
fun with that damn thing cruising
through the streets of Gotham this thing
hand
better than any grand theft auto car I
can promise you that but there are
scenes where you get ambushed by these
tanks you got to turn into a big tank
yourself you start gunning these tanks
down Batman like not really but what are
you going to do when there are tanks
occupying Gotham I can tell you just get
a tank yourself they still do a really
good job at making it feel like you're
not murdering people with this thing the
tanks that you're fighting fully
unmanned when you hit people with the
car they get electrocuted and bounced
out of the way so they're not dead and
when you're shooting your cams like Bam
Bam Bam and then it runs across a dude
it's like stun pellet Bam Bam Bam Bam
and they're like alright not dead but if
you're using the Batmobile to get around
Gotham it detracts from the fun of using
your grapple hook to glide across Gotham
like you did in Arkham City it's like
they knew that and they were like
alright you can use the Batmobile to
launch yourself out of the Batmobile so
you can go farther and faster so they
use the batma be able to go along with
the grapple mechanic and I love that
because in reality if I'm going around
Gotham I'm going on the rooftops I don't
want to take the streets because I want
to be Batman it does get kind of
annoying for the Riddler death traps
that have to use the Batmobile and the
scenarios where you have to use it in
the game for the story man ultimately
the biggest boss fight in the game has
to do with the Batmobile you're in the
Batmobile the entire time which makes it
impersonal for the boss fight ultimately
this game didn't have a lot of boss
fights it had confrontations that had
scenarios but ultimately their story
based which I understand people have a
problem with that I really do I just
don't as much because my favorite
chapter in the Legacy of Kain series is
Soul Reaver - and there are zero bosses
in that game no bosses doesn't take away
from the fact that you're still Batman
prowling on the rooftops taken down
goons if you like the Batman you don't
need a boss to do that and there are
moments with this game where you team up
with Nightwing or Robin or Catwoman and
when you're doing combat you can push l1
you do a dual team takedown now you're
controlling the other person it's so
seamless the way they switch you between
the characters I was like that's genius
why isn't it in this game more and I
love the Scarecrow's ultimately the guy
running the show he's the big terrorist
and Gotham going hey I'm gonna wipe this
city out the other villain that pops on
the scene
that's the arkham knight and all things
being truthful i wasn't really impressed
with the arkham knight himself he's
menacing when you come across him he
hates batman you love that but trying to
figure out in your own mind who the
arkham knight is is more fun and more
satisfying than the actual reveal of who
the arkham knight is i found it kind of
underwhelming the fact that the game is
named after him should be called batman
Harken fear gas city place I don't know
the Arkham Knight himself can just carry
the title of this game I don't know if
he deserves it another thing this game
does that I really love is explore
Batman's psyche he's kind of losing his
mind at this point from the events of
the last game and the game before that
it shows in this game and they explore
that in a really interesting way I loved
it it made for a great storytelling
element one of my favorite parts of the
game but ultimately if I'm being honest
even though Batman Arkham Knight ups the
gameplay factor in every way you think
it could whether it be the combat the
tech the takedowns it is next level the
plot of Batman Arkham City I liked more
than the plot of Batman Arkham Knight
just the plot of Batman Arkham City
started out one way and by the end
you're like this has just grown
astronomically to this endgame type
scenario they're throwing everything
into this game how can there even be a
next game arkham knight starts out you
have to take down the Scarecrow and take
down the arkham knight and it ends with
you having to take down the Scarecrow
and take down the arkham knight it's not
as much evolution in the plot itself
however that doesn't mean it doesn't
have a great plot it does I'm just
saying I prefer Arkham City's because
just one of the best games ever guys in
the end I had a blast with arkham knight
i got gamer insomnia you know how you
just stay up all night playing this game
and you go to sleep and you dream about
the game and you wake up and you just
play the game again it has a ton of
extras a ton of side missions everything
you need to keep you entertained in a
Batman Arkham game during game and
postgame and yeah I'm telling you you
don't actually get the ending to the
game until you get 100% of the game
which is really interesting they did it
that way it's not like you get an ending
and now you get the better ending it's
like you beat the game you don't get an
ending unless you actually become the
Batman and take your city back holy
I had fun with the Batmobile as long as
I was free running when they shove it
down your throat you can deal with it
until it starts getting annoying and
you're like alright pull it back I don't
want to have to use the Batmobile if I
can just be Batman and fly or Glide
it's really what he does Batman Arkham
Knight is a satisfying conclusion to the
Batman Arkham trilogy making the batman
arkham trilogy one of the best game
trilogies you can buy right now because
Arkham Knight is awesome tacular
don't buy this on the PC oh my god
I guess the PC port has a myriad of
problems I'm sorry PC users god knows
what witchcraft caused that to
happen my heart cries for you and goes
on I played it on ps4
okay so Arkham Knight have you played it
what did you think about it what's the
order of your favorite Arkham games
whatever you think whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more